first thing I wanted to ask you is has
your approach to producing Hunger Games
movies changed from 2015 to now because
it's only been eight years but there's
been a seismic shift in like
distribution models and how people like
to consume content um you know I would
say that it you know it has changed
because also like I'm always learning on
the job so I've learned a lot in the
last eight years I've also made a lot
more television so that really
influenced is your approach to
production what you believe is possible
um and what you think you can get done
in a day really changes when you switch
from features to TV and I think Francis
and I both really felt the benefit of
having done uh television in the
intervening years and how it informed
our approach to production this time
around I have to follow up on something
you just said can you name something
that you accomplished on this set that
would make maybe you producing the very
first Hunger Games movie go like my my
God I cannot believe we'd be able to
pull off that with one of these films
one day well I mean some of it is just
some of the audacity of it honestly if
somebody said to you you know you're GNA
I mean we started out shooting these
movies you know first one was in North
Carolina and then we moved on in the
subsequent movies to Atlanta and then
either Paris and Berlin or Atlanta and
Hawaii so we you know and this one we
shot all in Eastern Europe but if you
had told me that you'd be able to shut
down Carl marks Ali like this iconic
Street in the middle of Berlin that was
like the emblem of East Berlin at the
peak of its powers um and that we would
be able to make our
Capital
um unfold this way right in the heart of
Berlin I I would not have believed you
given how much inventing we did early on
and then to switch like say to a
European based production with an
amazing production designer and to see
this incredible architecture that we had
available to us and how much we were
able to do practically was amazing yes
you feel the effects of that while
you're watching the film I have to go
back to the very beginning and ask you a
question I feel like you might have been
asked before but this was one of the
first things that crossed my mind when I
finished reading the book did you ever
consider splitting ballot of song birds
and snakes into two movies instead of
one we never really did I think Francis
and I both felt that like it was very
hard for us to ever figure out how to do
Mocking Jay all in one but I also feel
the audiences get they get frustrated
when you leave them hanging and they
even if you're doing it from the inside
out they feel like it's from the outside
in they feel like oh you're just trying
to like maximize your upside and we felt
like no this is meant to be one story
this is the story of you know the the
birth of a villain and how does is a a a
young man who's not set in who he is
who's still figuring out who he is
become you know the man who we now know
as president Cory Ela snow where does
that turn happen and why does it happen
um so that was really what we you know
set out to understand another thing I
have wondered because I remember I think
it was in 2017 there was some news that
broke that you were considering hunger
gam spin-offs and that was before Ballad
of song birds and snakes existed would
you ever even at this point continue the
franchise without Source material from
Suzanne to work with I you know for me
like Suzanne is my North Star if she has
a story she wants to tell I am ready
willing and able to tell it um if there
were a story she wanted to tell that
wasn't based on a book but was an idea
of hers that she knew what she wanted to
do with it I'd be up for that I just
would never do any of it without her at
my side I just she's you know
I she is U the source of all things
relevant and important to these series
and you know I would never presume to
know um how to do it without her I have
so much respect for that mentality but
I'm going to ask you personally if there
is one corner of any of these books you
would want to explore further and build
a story out of what would you choose and
why well I personally have a lot of
curiosity about uh District 13 and the
idea of like this District that was once
like you know beloved and what did they
do to be bombed out of existence why did
they defy and I'm always really curious
like did they defy because they weren't
willing to send people to the Hunger
Games you know their own kids to the
Hunger Games why did this kind of like
you know uh favored child become the
bastard child of the of of the country
and why did they defy the capital when
nobody else did that always interested
me sign me up for that idea this new
movie has also made me even more
obsessed with Tigress because Hunter's
performance is absolutely perfect so I
want a whole movie for that character oh
I can for sure live with a lot more
Tigress yeah so going into the
production with this one now of all of
the scenes or the locations or anything
that you had to tackle to make this
movie happen at the beginning of
production which one did you think would
be the most difficult to pull off and
then ultimately was that the most
challenging or did a different scene
Catch You by surprise um I mean the some
of the things that we hope to accomplish
in terms of being able to like see shut
down Carl marks oi like I was like
they're never gonna let us do that we're
never going to be able to do that and
amazingly we had such an incredible team
on the ground that we were able to get
access to these locations there was a
lot of question about like some of our
locations whether we could afford them
like the amazing location where the um
tributes are interviewed by their
mentors and that with like incredibly
dramatic like powerful fascist
architecture that makes you feel so tiny
um that sequence was up in the air
because we had to go to leig for like
two days and like that's never like a
Studio's favorite thing is we're going
to go to a different city and move our
whole crew and cast for two days but
once we saw that location we were like
we have to have that location and we
have to figure out how to hold on to it
so there were kind of those fights along
the way of like how do you hold on to
the things that you think would really
have an impact and how do you give up
things that you think you might not need
you know like do you have to have as
he's walking to school an explosion or
could you go to liveig instead and those
kinds of things it makes sense another
high priority thing I have to ask you
about because it was something that was
on my mind after reading the book is
incorporating the music what
conversations did you have with with
Francis Rachel and the rest of the team
in order to make sure that Lucy's Lucy
Gray's music always felt like like
beautiful and pristine but also raw and
real within that world well I mean I
think that was always a big question is
knowing that on the one hand with a
musical theater background Rachel has
the capacity to sing and act at the same
time and to do both really well because
it's hard to do either one well let
alone both at the same time and
certainly Lucy gray is the performer we
talked a lot about like Dolly Parton as
an inspiration of somebody whose goal is
to entertain and not to um there's
nothing dactic about her she is want
everybody to feel that her music is made
for them that this song is for you and
so we wanted in in in Rachel somebody
who could make every person in the
audience feel like she's singing this
song to me and what it feels like for
someone like snow to know she actually
really is singing this song to me but
being able to find somebody in Rachel
who could deliver that and yet bring the
rawness and not go into like flip the
switch and go to like show tune mode but
actually really believing that this is
you know um that this is her music that
she's written this music and that this
is like the music that uh embodies her
experience and I also love of course how
you know Suzanne felt that these stories
that are passed on through songs and
then you think about how these stories
are passed on and these songs and the
impact they have on Katniss all those
years later is something really fun I
think Nails it perfectly cast J very
well done with her thank you thank you
so much and
congratulations